make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so a lot of you guys really seemed to
enjoy the video that we did when we
talked about the Joker right and indeed
those are the kind of videos that we
used to make when I first launched this
channel six years ago we used to ask
these philosophical questions for
example does Galactus consuming worlds
fall into the category of being good or
evil or is it neither a lot of the guys
really seemed to enjoy those in this
video I want to ask a question that may
not even really have a definitive answer
but I want to see if we can find one I
want to ask the question do people need
superheroes so the reality of asking a
question like this is that people would
not ask this question if superheroes had
been around for 20 years this is a
question people would ask if superheroes
had popped up for the very first time
and so what I'd like you to do here is
to remove yourself from this real world
and I want you to imagine yourself in
this world of comic books and I want you
to imagine that superheroes had
basically just become something the
Society was aware of which is to say
Peter Parker has just become spider-man
maybe the Avengers have just formed for
the first time but whatever the scenario
is superheroes have just now risen to
prominence and as so many people have
just become aware of with that in mind
people would most likely adapt the
scenario or adapt to the question of
asking how do we compare to these
various superheroes which is to say what
role do people play in society absent
superheroes for us as people we create
laws and standards by which society
exists ie we create a social contract
now the reason for why we create these
social contracts is relative to what
Philosopher's you're looking at for
example if you looked at Thomas Hobbes
Thomas Hobbes argue that when society
exists in a state of nature registers
say no order government whatsoever that
people would basically kill steal and
enslave others in order to ensure their
own survival and their own safety and
they would be allowed to it's the only
natural right that individuals high to
do whatever it is they need to do in
order to stay alive
but because this would be an exceedingly
harsh and brutal environment this would
inevitably lead to what he referred to
as a perpetual and permanent war ball
against all and so in order to ensure
that society itself did not devolve into
this constant state of war that people
would sacrifice this natural right to do
whatever they needed to do in order to
live and create a government which in
turn would come with a set of rules that
you
can't steal you can't kill someone and
so forth a place for them to air their
grievances which he referred to as the
Leviathan however if you look at someone
like John Locke John Locke argued that
in a state of nature the rights of men
and women were not limited to doing
whatever it was they needed to do in
order to survive instead that the rights
of individuals were inalienable that
people had the right to life liberty and
property something that would be carried
over in future philosophers and even the
framers of the US Constitution the
result was that in order to ensure that
these rights were maintained that
individuals would form an organized
government to protect these various
rights but regardless of how you slice
it that coming together of an organized
society and the formation of a
government for that society is designed
to maintain and to ensure the survival
of the rights and the lives of the
people involved it's the reason why we
create laws that say it's illegal to
steal not because we morally believe
that stealing is wrong
but because if stealing is illegal it
means you cannot steal from me and if
you do I have legal recourse for that
and so this takes us into the second
role that once this social contract is
established and what's this organized
society it's on its way we create
systems by which this social contract
can be enforced we create judges we
create police officers individuals that
we can go to in order to air a grievance
with regards to a violation of this
social contract and in turn for those
individuals who did violate this social
contract the third role comes into play
and that we provide punishments for
those who violate this contract either
they're sentenced to jail or depending
on the severity of the crime committed
we may even take their lives by virtue
of execution and so the question becomes
this if social contracts or laws as
they're more commonly referred to you
and the resulting government are formed
managed and enforced by society then
what need is there for superheroes why
not simply continue to rely on police
and judges to ensure that those who
violate the laws are punished adequately
to answer this we have to ask what do
superheroes actually do and are the
tasks that they undertake beyond the
ability for society to handle on its own
on a surface level superheroes fight bad
guys it's the most fundamental aspect of
who they are sometimes superheroes fight
villains who have a kind of
technological advantage over Society
maybe they're smarter than everybody
else maybe they have some giant warship
that they use to rain down fire on a
city other
time's superheroes fight villains who
possess a level of power this society
simply isn't prepared to face off
against somebody like magneto who can
manipulate and control the entire
electromagnetic spectrum or somebody
like copycat who can become anyone and
even duplicate the powers of others but
regardless superheroes fight villains
who if the superheroes did not exist
would be able to successfully conquer
all of society or even destroy society
itself using whatever intelligence
powers or technology they have at their
disposal but on a more philosophical
level superheroes reflect what society
strives to be better but then that begs
the question why do people need
superheroes to inspire them why can't
they simply just become better the
reality is that as people we are
imperfect and we are oftentimes more
emotional than we are logical when it
comes to committing crimes for example
Agnes Heller from the new school of
Social Research argued people commit
crimes under one of three circumstances
either they believe that they simply
cannot get caught they commit crimes of
passion which simply cannot be deterred
or they plan their crime so the
consequences didn't matter to them a
2016 study from science report revealed
that people tend to take their
worldviews and tie them into their
identity and so when somebody comes
across them with a differing political
belief it's not viewed as your belief is
different than mine it's viewed as you
don't like what I like therefore you
don't like me
however for individuals with
extraordinary powers while they are
viewed as people at their core insofar
as they have their own struggles they
have their own life crises that they go
through and they have their own crisis
of conscience where sometimes they don't
know what the right decision is
seemingly they always seem to make the
right choice that they've moved beyond
this base perception of I am the most
important person in the world and what
matters to me should matter to everybody
else and instead their allegiances are
to what's best for society as a whole
and so to wrap back around and find an
answer to this question do people need
superheroes I would say the answer is
yes because as people we oftentimes get
caught up in our own lives we get caught
up in the various circumstances that
we're facing with and we have a hard
time seeing anything beyond that we
oftentimes see the world through the
lens of our own experiences and we have
a hard time seeing the world through the
lenses of other people's experience and
the result of that is we get wrapped up
in
own lives with superheroes on the other
hand their duty and their allegiance is
to humanity as a whole it's through
society as a whole they have to put
their own struggles aside and ask
themselves what's better for the world
and that's what people are continually
striving to achieve people are
continually striving to move themselves
to a position where they view the world
is not just about them anymore people
are striving to move to a position to
where they can see the world in such a
way where they ask what's better for
society as a whole the reality is that
superheroes help to lead us to that
place superheroes help to get us to a
place worse not just about us anymore
where it's about everybody else around
us in addition to us and so I think we
have a pretty reasonable answer here
again there's not really a definitive
answer to this question right there's
not an absolute answer here this isn't
really a two plus two equals four
formula it's not as straightforward as
the video that we did on the Joker but
it does ask some pretty interesting
questions and it does require us to
offer some pretty significant
self-examination with regards to us
living in a world of superheroes what
those superheroes have to offer and how
those superheroes can lead us to become
better people but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end definitely more metaphysical than
the ones that we've done in the past but
I like that I like having you know
asking questions they don't really have
definitive answers because it really is
open to interpretation and I want to
open the floor to you guys I want to
know what you all think about this do
you guys really believe that people need
superheroes or do you think people are
capable of becoming the better versions
of themselves without the help of
superheroes it's kind of an interesting
question so let me said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end I look
forward to seeing your answers down in
the comments section if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you